Mais il reste que nous achetons des assurances
pour nous protéger financièrement
de ces éventualités, non ?
Alors, par l'investissement durable
nous faisons deux choses.
Nous nous assurons
en résuisant le risque pour notre planète et notre économie
et en même temps, à court terme,
nous ne sacrifions pas la perfomance.
[Et si tout ça était une fumisterie et que nous créons un monde meilleur pour rien ? » ]
C'est bien, vous l'aimez. Je l'aime aussi.
(Rires)
Je l'aime parce qu'on y trouve à rire
des deux côtés adverses du problème du changement climatique.
Je parie que vous ne savez pas de quel côté je suis.
Mais, ce que j'aime vraiment de ce dessin,
c'est qu'il me rappelle quelque chose que Mark Twain a dit :
« Planifiez votre futur,
car c'est là que vous passerez
le reste de votre vie ».
Merci.
(Applaudissements)